ok freuen wir sind bereit für ein paar
schlagzeilen die führte deines partners
verlängern dein leben fuß zu schützen
vor krankheiten warum die truppe des
partners ihr leben verlängern können es
werden ja immer wieder total verrückte
dinge
wissenschaftlich bewiesen so verrückt
dass man sich denkt das kann ja gar
nicht
andererseits gibt es ja auch total
verrückte studie zum beispiel diese
studie wo forscher berechnet haben mit
wie viel druck pinguine kacken es ist
also gar nicht mehr so einfach zu sagen
ob schlagzeilen stimmen oder nicht
deswegen herzlich willkommen zu unserem
neuen format schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft heute mit ist
fuchs riechen gesund hier eine
garantiert wissenschaftliche antwort und
so viel verspreche ich euch
es wird spannend so wichtige sache
zuerst man sollte artikel niemals nur
nach der schlagzeile oder überschrift
beurteilen deswegen lass doch mal
schauen was genau am pupsen so gesund
sein soll eine studie der britischen
university of exeter fand heraus dass es
gut ist führt zu einzuordnen menschliche
flatulenzen enthalten einen stoff namens
hydrogen soll vize der das risiko
verschiedener krankheiten reduzieren
kann
einschließlich krebs schlaganfälle und
herzinfarkte so viel stimmt hydrogen
solid oder die hitze gehen so viel
müsste man sagen ist das äquivalent zu
unserem h2o zum wasser nur mit schwefel
schwefelwasserstoff versagt man meistens
dazu oder einfach nur kurz hsh zwar es
ist ein stinkendes gas dem unsere 14
ihren gesang zu verdanken haben also
unsere kürze enthalten auch noch andere
stinke moleküle aber hat zwar es ist
schon einer der maine player h2 es
riecht nach verfaulten eiern und zwar
brutal das weiß ich als chemikerin leid
aus eigener erfahrung weil man im labor
auch ab und an mit h2s hantiert in einem
pups ist h2s relativ verdünnt denn ein
furz besteht zum größten teil aus
geruchlosen gasen aber wir wissen alle
dass auch solche kleinen konzentrationen
schon ausreichend unangenehm sein können
im labor hingegen gearbeitet man
normalerweise mit dem reinen gas das
beim einatmen übrigens giftig ist und
dass ab einer gewissen konzentration den
geruchssinn betäubt das heißt wenn ihr
mal im labor mit h2s arbeiten solltet
und es plötzlich nicht mehr stinkt dann
kippte verkauf ok und warum sollte man
das jetzt schnüffeln obwohl hydrogen so
viel dafür bekannt ist ein penetrant
faulig riechendes gas aus verfaulten
eiern oder flatulenzen zu sein ist es
eigentlich ein gesundheits hält und wird
ganz natürlich vom körper produziert na
ja wie gesagt es ist auch ein gift aber
die dosis macht das gift und h2 es wird
tatsächlich in winzigen kontrollierten
mengen auch in unseren zellen produziert
in diesem bild artikel wird erklärt die
trugen soll hitz soll gut sein für die
mitochondrien die kraftwerke der zellen
auch das stimmt mittendrin sind die
kraftwerke unserer zellen sie halten
unsere zellen also am leben wären der
mitochondrien geschädigt dann kann das
zusammenhängen mit verschiedenen
krankheiten wie herzversagen
schlaganfälle diabetes demenz auf
molekularer ebene spielt hier der
sogenannte oxidative stress eine rolle
dabei entstehen reaktive aggressive
sauerstoffverbindungen oxidationsmittel
die die zelle schädigen oder töten
können für solche fälle hat das mit
contrium aber methoden sich zu schützen
es unter oxidativen stress gerät
bestellt es enzyme die h2s produzieren
in ganz kleinen mengen und dieses jahr
zwar ist hilft ihr mit eurem dabei durch
zypern und die zelle am leben zu halten
insofern hilft harz war es bei dem
schutz vor krankheiten diesen
körpereigenen wie toronto ein
überlebensmechanismus versuchen jetzt
forscher zu imitieren sie versuchen
jetzt medikamente herzustellen
die genau wie diese enzyme auch h2s
produzieren in kleinen kontrollierten
mengen genauso auch in dieser studie das
ist nämlich die studie auf die sich
diese ganzen
putze riechen ist gesund schlagzeilen
beziehen aber warum jetzt so mühsam h2s
medikamente entwickeln wenn man doch
stattdessen einfach am putzen schlüsseln
kann bald es hat ein unterschied macht
ob man etwas einatmet und dann auch noch
unbestimmte mengen davon
oder man etwas die ziel im innern einer
zelle kontrolliert freisetzt es ist
jetzt nicht prinzipiell abwegig dass ein
wirkstoff nicht auch über das einatmen
über die lunge ins innere unserer zellen
gelangen könnte aber diese form der
zulieferung ist sicherlich nicht
besonders kontrolliert oder
zielgerichtet damit das glas die
forscher haben h2s einatmen nicht
untersucht vor allem weil es auch nicht
chemisch biologisch plausibel wäre dass
das irgendetwas bringt geschweige denn
untersucht wie es ist buße einzuatmen
das ist in dieser studie noch nicht mal
ansatzweise passiert schaut man in die
pressemitteilung der uni so werden
führte zwar auch als lustige aufhänger
benutzt aber auch hier steht nirgends
dass man führt zu einer atmen sollte das
heißt pups riechen ist nicht gilt und
all diese überschriften und die
grundlegenden behauptungen in diesen
artikeln sind alle falsch
gerade bei populärwissenschaft ist es
leider oft so dass irgendjemand
irgendetwas verrücktes über eine studie
schreibt und andere das einfach
aufgreifen nachplappern kopieren ihre
eigenen artikel schreiben verbreiten
ohne die originale studie zu lesen habe
ich auch wer auf die idee kam jetzt
speziell die puppe des partners zum
thema zu machen wir wissen zwar nicht
warum zu hören der forscher die puppe
von paaren untersucht haben
vielleicht weil die forscher das nie
untersucht haben so sicher wäre ich mit
noch nicht mal wie gesagt es gibt echt
seltsam studien wenn euch dieses format
gefallen hat dann lasst es mich wissen
dann macht das in zukunft gerne wieder
aber am besten noch mit eurer hilfe das
heißt wenn ihr irgendwo eines der rückte
schlagzeile seht über eine studie die
mal wieder irgendetwas gezeigt hat und
ihr wissen wollt ob es stimmt oder nicht
dann teil diesen link über twitter mit
mir oder mit lars und dem hashtag prüft
die schlagzeilen natürlich könnt ihr
auch sehr gerne schlagzeilen unter
diesem hashtag in die kommentare
schreiben nur achtung kommentare mit
links während von youtube automatisch in
den spam-ordner geschoben das heißt wenn
ihr sicher gehen
dann am besten einfach nur die
schlagzeile als text kopieren und als
kommentar posten ich kann das dann auch
selber googeln also hashtag prüft die
schlagzeile wir sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher ich muss mir so
nein